[Musik]
hallo aus peking genauer gesagt aus dem
zug der gerade aus peking herausführt
richtung unseres hotels steffi wir
hätten das video gern im nationalstadion
aufgenommen wo gerade die
eröffnungsfeier statt gefunden hat aber
wieder rausgeschmissen
das ging alles sehr schnell das kann man
der durch gesagt wir müssen direkt raus
in 15 minuten verletzte brust so kam mir
nicht mehr weg deswegen müssen wir uns
ein bisschen beeilen und konnten das
leider nicht mehr vor ort drehen
deswegen jetzt video hier aus dem zug
das sind für uns ja die ersten
olympischen winterspiele als
reporterinnen und reporter vor ort
steffi was war dein eindruck von der
eröffnungsfeier ja also es war sehr bunt
sehr viele tänze vielleicht auch zu
viele
kinder jugendliche
sportlerin ja wirklich alles wurde
gezeigt was china zu bieten hat
sehr durchchoreografiert jeder ja jeder
beifall war glaub ich vorher ein
bisschen abgesprochen man hat gemerkt wo
die sympathien lagen weil thomas bach
wurde sehr laut applaudiert
natürlich auch bei xing ping
das war zu erwarten und
ja also die geschichte an sich ist jetzt
nicht klar geworden also wollte uns
diese schau jetzt irgendwas erzählen
da konnte man nicht so ganz den roten
faden erkennen
ja thomas bach wir uns schon mal kurz
angesprochen es war eine sehr
eindrückliche szene als die beiden sich
begrüßt haben ist er so langsam ab ihn
zugelaufen hat sich verneigt sie haben
sich mehrfach zugewunken wie hast du das
nicht erlebt also genau damit du meinst
shipping werde thomas bach diese tribüne
hoch gelaufen kamera auf sie gerichtet
thomas bach verbeugt sich shipping
verbeugt sich nicht ist ja auch ein bild
das für sich spricht und auch für
einfach dieses größeres thema politisch
also olympischer spiele das ist die
geschichte des erc die seien nicht
politisch aber in solchen momenten auch
grundsätzlich und auf die tribüne
geschaut hat man gesehen wie politisch
solche veranstaltungen doch sind
einladungen schaut wer da war und wer
nicht da war er war nicht da mit mir
gesehen wladimir putin der russische
russische präsident der der stargast der
chinesin der war da und dafür die
vertreter sag ich mal der der länder wo
vertreter noch demokratisch gewählt
werden
großbritannien australien kanada die
waren nicht da
[Musik]
ja in seiner ansprache hat der ioc
präsident thomas bach ziemlich häufig
angesprochen dass er china sehr dankbar
ist dass
die spiele jetzt in dieser pandemie also
einer sehr schwierigen zeit auf das
organisationskomitee ausrichten
die kann sich das denn jetzt auswirken
also china kann glaube ich gerade zwei
sachen zeigen sie zeigen so nach außen
der welt okay wir wir richten spiele
auch in dieser phase aus und diese
zweiten winter der pandemie und sie
können vor allem die ihre eigenen
bevölkerung zeigen okay wir haben die
welt bei uns zu gast und ich bin nach
unseren regeln gespielt alle strengen
maßnahmen die wir gesetzt haben die
beiden eingehalten keiner läuft nicht
schritt dahin will ich sein darf
wirklich alles ist total unter kontrolle
das ist auch der eindruck den dixie an
sein volk vermitteln will man das jetzt
mal so aus der ferne analysieren kann
und auch mit den kleinen bildern und
gesten werden einfache botschaften
gesehen wird auch als eigene volk eben
dass jetzt einer von denen von den zwei
also eine athletin die die flamme
entzündet hat kommt aus kenia also aus
dieser region wo die muslimische
minderheit der uiguren aufdrückt wird
das kann natürlich auch solche zeichen
interpretieren ok alles halb so wild wie
wir haben das auf dem schirm was
natürlich nicht so ist aber dass er
hatte diese bühne eben gut genutzt um
soll ich nachher positiv zu zeigen eine
solche botschaften nicht nur nach außen
an die welt sondern auch nach innen
vielleicht
[Musik]
und noch ein letztes zitat von thomas
bach dass wir auch seine rede bei der
eröffnungsfeier im aufgreifen wollen er
sagte ja die athleten gesprochen und
athletinnen die wegen der korona
pandemie jetzt nicht dabei sein können
können ihren traum nicht wahr werden
lassen können dann wird es jetzt auf die
nächste wochenende spiele stattfinden
spiegeln was gruppenreisen offen zu ja
natürlich wissen wir dass noch nicht
gibt so genau was auf uns zukommt aber
er meint damit natürlich die athleten
bereits vielleicht in quarantäne sind
oder der sportart absagen mussten weil
sie sich noch infiziert haben und gar
nicht anreisen konnten nach china
ja wahrscheinlich wird es so sein dass
es auch noch mehr sportler und
sportlerinnen wird und
das thema hängt natürlich so ein
bisschen wie ein damoklesschwert über
den athleten und bedrückt sie und es ist
natürlich ein zusätzlicher stress der da
auf sie einwirkt
wir hatten jetzt ja auch schon im
deutschen team einige fälle
ja natürlich kann es sein dass das
weiter interessiert oder ist vielleicht
ermöglicht sogar im thema drin ist
weiter begleitet wir ziehen jetzt
schnell wieder masken auf und melden uns
dann die tage wieder aus peking ja aber
oder eher gesagt aus landshut wurde
wohnende perner de ski langlauf biathlon
sport
da bist du gehst
[Musik]